uh but talk a little bit about the
decision to uh actually kind of open
source or provide
uh without cost um you know have all
this work that you've done over a number
of years and
what drove that yeah that's um i wish i
could take full credit for that that was
actually an important
kind of piece that naval wanted in the
book um
that i was very very happy to about you
know all of my writing
forever has been free um you know
evergreen was totally free and all my
blog posts are out there and stuff so
um that totally agreed with my ethos um
i didn't understand exactly
all of the reasons why that was so
important until actually this week so
publishing this week and getting
hundreds of tweets and dms and emails
from people all over the world
who don't have access to amazon or to
the kindle store
or whatever like i didn't even
realize how difficult it was for them to
get their hands on some of these things
like
pay pay like a side um
but to pay you know us dollars for a
book of ideas that could change
somebody's life in you know the
philippines like
that's a higher bar for them um not
everyone has you know
amazon service or a kindle or a device
to download a kindle on
but so putting it out there as a pdf and
free on the website like there are
people who are
very very grateful for that um and it's
kind of a transformative thing
um i think it is also you know i mean
it's been downloaded
tens of thousands of times already um so
it is clear that it adds value to people
i think enough people are gonna kind of
share this and appreciate it and and
there's a lot more to kind of do around
these ideas um
but but really naval has given all of
this you know these lessons away
i'm very happy to kind of add my um
curatorial efforts to it and and pay
that forward
you know the best i can and plenty of
people are going to
want to buy the book or we made it as
cheap as we can on amazon
um in the kindle store but amazon does
not want to do free hosting and
distribution it turns out so
they set they set price floors but
everything we made it available
for free on the website involvement.com
you can read the whole thing you can
download epub moby
pdf put it in your kindle print it out
whatever you want to do like
it's all out there got it uh are you
gonna write another one
maybe who do you wanna who do you wanna
see the almanac of next oh i'd have to
think hard
uh if you're gonna go spend three years
of your life it would have to be
somebody that beats that same quality
bar
i'm not gonna just throw a random name
out there and then you go uh
go do it if you if you think of it you
you send it you send it to me
um i'm not gonna rule it out but i'm
also not gonna just go
you know kind of crank them out to crank
them out um
there's there's actually i think a lot
to do around
around this book for for application and
tools and
services and things like that like this
book i think is just the beginning of
the journey for many people
on figuring out how to find their
specific knowledge
right like it takes many many years and
not everybody has the kind of advantages
of people around them who can
help them distill it or kind of make
prescriptive
recommendations on on what they should
be doing or make you know even have
healthy relationships business
relationships with them to kind of
coach them through some of these things
um you know there's definitely a lot to
learn
about the tools of leverage and you know
how many
ways there are to kind of buy back your
own time and work on high leverage tasks
and things like that like this is
something i think
you have done incredibly well but you
know with no playbook
that i can see just kind of like
intuiting your way forward
to figure out like what you are uniquely
really good at
how to find kind of tools that help you
get you know more reach and find more
audience and serve
the people who follow you better um so
that that is something that i think
you know there's a lot to kind of do and
unpack there and and
you know i don't know that i'm done with
um with these ideas just yet
one of the things that's really
interesting me and i you'll know i won't
uh
where where he said it but i think it
was in like the how to be rich
um kind of series of of audio clips
um but basically this idea of leverage
right
to me is uh we know that compounding uh
kind of was misunderstood to those now
who uh
look at building wealth that's kind of
you know now a uh
a discovered truth if you will right and
everyone kind of talks about it
leverage seems to be kind of in that
phase that compounding used to be right
where
uh there's so many people who understand
it but kind of the general mass
audience doesn't understand uh with any
level of mastery or really
kind of application why that's so
important
right and so do you think that this is
something where
uh simply hearing the ideas right kind
of the way he articulates it is enough
for people
or do you think that there is this
element of like this is almost the top
of the funnel
right where you got to kind of hear an
idea hear somebody explain it now that
you
you know trust and have legitimacy and
kind of all that stuff
and then they've got to kind of walk
through it but you actually don't
um kind of internalize it until you
actually put into application
so kind of how do you separate ideas
versus action here and kind of where do
you think this book fits
yeah i mean i think i'm i'm always a
proponent of the like
you don't actually understand it until
you've you've tested it against reality
until you've like heard the echo of what
you've put out there and
and see it work and see it in action um
i totally agree like leverage
is really i think pretty tangled up with
compounding in some ways like
the gap between you know you doing your
most high value tasks
is is is another thing that compounds
you know getting
getting leverage through capital giving
getting leverage through labor this is
why you see
you know the business owners pretty
consistently become
the wealthiest people because they are
leveraged and they're leveraged
through capital through labor and
through products and all of these things
kind of
the leverage itself compounds um and
gets bigger and bigger and all you know
the capital is compounding the labor is
compounding and that the profits are
coming back and getting reinvested and
so i think there's a lot to kind of
um continue to unpack there i think you
know to your point like people
definitely everyone parrots compounding
and everyone
understands that it's important but it
is still so counterintuitive and so
difficult for us to
you know even people who spent their
whole lives with with compounding and
studying it still have to
go look at the tables and be like oh
holy [ __ ] that is so much more than i
thought it would
like the mental math is still
counterintuitive and still surprisingly
high
um i think leverage is i
completely agree with you that it is
kind of like in the same
uh lane but lagging the understanding of
compounding and it's just
less a little less studied and
understood and a little less like
mathematically quantified yet in the way
that um
compounding is productized leveraged
probably in particular um and people are
seeing like
you know break out successes like joe
rogan or
um this kind of phenomenon of companies
getting smaller
or head count getting smaller and
companies getting bigger and so
you know instagram at a billion with 10
people and whatsapp
and you know bitcoin even like these
things are that that is all productized
leverage that people are still
not quite seeing as like the support
beam that it is for the outcomes that
we're seeing
i think it's absolutely huge i think
it's a really interesting
thing to kind of continue to study and
naval's um
broad classification of it as leverage
and just labeling it leverage really
helps us kind of
think about it you know we think of
labor as so different from capital and
so different from product until it's all
under the same umbrella
you kind of oh holy [ __ ] how can i like
mix and match these two is this a
problem that needs to be solved with
labor is it a problem that can be solved
with capital is there a problem that can
be solved with product how do i mix
these together
um which actually is the most expensive
or the most
the highest margin form of leverage for
this particular challenge that i'm
taking on like
there's a lot to explore there um and
i'm actually like
it's one of the concepts that i'm most
excited to kind of keep diving into and
kind of do my own
research on and keep writing on
hopefully and
see where that takes me to me one of the
aspects as you're reading through it and
kind of
really really like looking at the words
on a page right not just hearing a
podcast et cetera is it's very obvious
that
uh his command of these ideas is due to
his um application of them right and so
it's like
the idea of leverage like even the way
that he describes the various types of
leverages
he specifically highlights not just
software right not just human capital he
also talks about
blogs and podcasts and like like he
really really understands that when you
kind of take a step back like
because he's done all of it right and so
did you get the sense
that um he has this ability to
articulate these ideas
because of his specific experience or do
you think that this is something where
anyone who sat and just thought about
this stuff for a long time could kind of
come to the same conclusions and have
the same
uh command of the descriptions in these
ideas
yeah i think it i think it takes some
experience with reality
some operating experience to kind of get
um not not just
fluent with these concepts but to have
them distilled so powerfully
you know um it is a very non-academic
thing right it's not a guy who's studied
a bunch of different things and wrote a
big paper with a bunch of confusing
words
about you know how leverage applies it
is like a man who has built and invested
in
you know he built a few successful
businesses he's invested in hundreds of
successful businesses
and he has this kind of like mental
model
of how these things come about and what
he's looking for
um and that is just you know and in a
few kind of simple words can explain
that
and now he's been studying these things
he says he formulated some of these
things when he was 14 and just like
you know a poor immigrant kid in new
york looking around trying to figure out
how the world works and how people get
money and how to become successful
so he's been distilling these principles
for decades and
applying them and learning them and so
um you know
even there's a blog post from 2008 that
is like
surprised me with how far back it was
there was some of these kind of basic
equations you know your income
equals your specific knowledge plus
accountability
plus leverage you know very basic
formula it doesn't mean anything to you
until you've read the other until you
can unpack all those words into the
things that he's been thinking about for
10 years
which is kind of what this book does but
it really surprised me how
how long he's been thinking about it and
it shows you like
you know this clarity comes from years
of distillation and practice
and application and and receiving kind
of
um feedback from the universe that these
theories are correct
and once they're in your head you're
looking around at other people
seeing how you know you see this formula
everywhere and you start to see
how um how people take accountability
how they use specific knowledge how they
use leverage
and it almost becomes a formula for kind
of um understanding
how they became successful or how they
continue to grow and and that's really
where you start to
see how you can apply it for yourself
you know that that's where you get to
the
301 401 like oh i i see the world
differently now and now i understand if
i push this button this thing can happen
now i understand if i start this
business it can become profitable with
the use of these tools these
these pieces of leverage instead of just
you know trying to do everything
manually
um and you understand the difference
between you know
the level of accountability that an
hourly worker has versus
their manager versus the owner of the
business like these are things that not
everyone
is is lucky enough to ever see how the
world works and how
why some people are successful and why
um others are getting wealthy and
and some aren't that is um i find that
to be a very valuable
thing to just understand the truths of
some of these things and
um see the forces that are at work
yeah it's it's really really interesting
to kind of hear you
navigate that balance between just
thinking and doing
um what what happens next will you
continue to update this and kind of on
an annual
or every few year basis uh i'm assuming
that
naval is not going to stop doing or
thinking uh
nor putting more information out there
like how do you think about uh kind of
the evolution
of uh his thoughts in regards to the
book
yeah it depends um i think it depends a
little bit
on many things but what he does what he
shares
i worked very hard to ensure that
everything in the book is evergreen
um so i hope that the book itself will
never go out of date or become
non-applicable um naval i'm sure we'll
continue to share many
great insights and and new things um if
we needed an
updated version in you know 10 years or
something like
we can we could talk about that um i
definitely continue to
will continue to kind of update the site
and and write more there
um i've got a mailing list when they've
all comes out with great new stuff i'll
share it
um i may continue to kind of try to
expand on some of these ideas on the
blog
share more about how the book came about
and what is happening as a result of the
book
um you know some of the stuff we talked
about around
how to help people you know go further
with these ideas how to get more
you know in tune with their specific
knowledge how to apply leverage um
might be something that we we do um
i don't know the whole last section of
the book is recommended reading
uh so there's all these kind of great
books across philosophy
and you know non-fiction you know
there's a bunch of matt ridley
and talib and one of the things that
i've heard is that a reading group
might be really interesting for people
who want to kind of get together and
study naval's recommendations and his
ideas and create a you know kind of a
little like
naval university if you want to swim
deeper into these ideas let's go into
the source material together
let's really you know ask each other
some of the hard questions hold each
other accountable for for doing the hard
work of studying some of these kind of
basic you know source texts you know
it's
not easy work to read the origin of
species or um
you know go all the way back to some of
the early philosophers but
if that's you know what you want to hold
yourself to like it's easier to do that
as part of a group
yeah makes uh makes a lot of sense um if
anyone wants to uh buy the book the
almanac of naval ravikant a guide to
wealth and happiness they can go to
navalmenace.com
uh is the best place to buy the the
hardcover and then
you can also download the uh the pdf uh
or other versions
for uh for free there